tenemos la función fx igual a 2x al cubo
más 5x al cuadrado menos 7 y todo eso
elevado a la 8 y lo que queremos es
encontrar la derivada de nuestra función
fx ahora lo que tenemos que hacer aquí
es darnos cuenta que nuestra función
efe de x se puede escribir como la
composición de dos funciones y cómo
hacemos eso pues vamos a hacer un
diagrama digamos que empezamos con una
equis y que es lo primero que hacemos si
fuéramos a evaluar a la función en
cierta equis seguramente lo primero que
haríamos es calcular 2 x al cubo más 5 x
al cuadrado menos 7 para esa x entonces
qué tal que nos imaginamos por aquí una
función que haga justo esa parte que
esta función simplemente evalúe 2 x al
cubo más 5 x al cuadrado menos 7 para
cada una de las equis bueno a esta
función le vamos a llamar la función u y
sea cual sea la entrada que le demos a
esta función y lo que vamos a obtener es
2 por esa entrada elevada al cubo más 5
por esa entrada elevada al cuadrado
menos 7 y cuando le damos una entrada x
a esta función que es lo que obtenemos
bueno pues obtenemos la salida y de x lo
cual es igual a 2 por esa x al cubo más
5 por esa x al cuadrado menos 7 y bueno
vamos a escribirlo por aquí pero con un
solo color para no tener que cambiar
tanto de color entonces tenemos 2 x x al
cubo
5 x x al cuadrado menos 7 esto es de x y
ahora qué es lo siguiente que tenemos
que hacer porque todavía no terminamos
después de evaluar de x y obtener este
valor todavía tenemos que elevarlo a la
potencia 8
así es que tomamos este valor y lo
usamos como entrada en otra función
vamos a llamarle a esa función b y esta
función lo que hace es que cualquier
entrada que le des estoy usando unos
cuadrados para representar a esas
entradas pero lo que hace la ve es tomar
esa entrada y elevarla a la potencia 8 y
en este caso con esta función lo que
obtenemos si le damos como entrada de x
be evaluada en o de equis pero de equis
tiene este valor de aquí entonces esto
también lo podemos ver como ve que
evaluada en 2 x al cubo más 5 x al
cuadrado menos 7 y por supuesto esto
también lo podemos ver como 2 x al cubo
más 5 x al cuadrado menos 7 y todo eso
elevado a la potencia 8 y eso es justo
lo que tenemos en fx así es que lo que
acabamos de ver es que la función fx se
puede escribir como la composición de
dos funciones la función be compuesta
por un estas dos funciones juntas son
efe de x ponemos una equis de entrada a
la función fx y obtenemos esto de aquí
así es que podemos escribir a la función
f de x como la función be evaluada en la
función o en x y entonces podemos
utilizar la regla de la cadena que nos
dice que f prima de x es igual a la
derivada de toda esta función con
respecto a lo cual se traduce
simplemente en la derivada de b evaluada
en y de x y luego tenemos que
multiplicar por la derivada de y con
respecto a x que la derivada de y con
respecto a x evaluada en x
ahora tenemos que encontrar estas dos
derivadas pero es posible que ya las
conozcamos muy bien porque aquí ud x q
de x es igual a 2 por x al cubo
5 x al cuadrado menos 7 y entonces la
derivada de su prima de x aquí
simplemente vamos a utilizar la derivada
de las potencias así es que aquí tenemos
3 x 2 6 por x a la tres menos uno o sea
al cuadrado más 2 por 5 10 por x a la 2
- 1
o sea simplemente x y luego la derivada
de una constante simplemente 0 por lo
que ya no tenemos que sumar nada más por
acá entonces ya tenemos la derivada de
evaluada en x y ahora nada más tenemos
que calcular la derivada de b pero ve si
la evaluaremos en una x v de x sería
igual a x elevado a la potencia 8 y
entonces b prima de x utilizando la
regla de la derivada de las potencias
nuevamente sería 8 x
elevado a la potencia 7 y por lo tanto
de prima evaluada en o de x es igual a 8
por y de x elevada a la potencia 7
cualquier cosa que evaluemos en be prima
la elevamos a la potencia 7 y la
multiplicamos por 8 entonces si
evaluamos a ver prima en v x elevamos a
de x a la potencia 7 y la multiplicamos
por 8 ahora esta expresión la tenemos
por acá entonces b prima de v x es igual
a 8
ud x que es 2 x al cubo más 5 x al
cuadrado menos 7 y elevamos a ud x a la
potencia 7 y listo ya terminamos efe
prima de x es igual a b prima evaluada
en ud x que lo acabamos de calcular es
esto que tenemos aquí que es 8 x 2 x al
cubo más 5 x al cuadrado menos 7 elevado
a la potencia 7 y luego por prima de x
pero prima de x la tenemos por aquí que
es
6x al cuadrado más 10 x más adelante vas
a poder reconocer esto muy rápido y no
vas a tener que escribir todo lo que
escribimos por aquí muchas de estas
cosas las vas a poder hacer como un
cálculo mental por ejemplo aquí vas a
poder decir primero voy a tomar la
derivada de la función exterior que si
tuviéramos aquí una equis tendríamos x a
la 8 y su derivada sería 8 por equis
elevado a las 7 y entonces vamos a tener
8 por todo lo que tenemos aquí elevado a
las 7 aunque como lo tenemos acá y luego
ya nada más nos falta sacar la derivada
de lo que tenemos adentro que es 6 por x
al cuadrado más 10 x